so do you ever look back at the emails
from that time no I never got emails I
didn't send an email nobody I didn't
send an email to anybody to like 2003
that's the first email I ever sent
anybody really it was like mm so you had
it for years and just didn't use it no
and king of Technology almost
among comedians like it well not like
nerd stuff but like you're in all social
media platforms and so yeah but I can't
tell it like I'm not an Instagram I'm
not blurry every [ __ ] day every
[ __ ] day I get four requests for
linking with you socially what I've said
it a thousand times
I don't know more business people it's
like business for holes for people who
do I have to bother a [ __ ] baby see
if I bothered you and then you bother me
back I know nothing one day I started
getting [ __ ] friendship request from
business invitations to be my friend I'm
like who is this what is this Lincoln
then ignore I don't know nothing I just
erase him now every day I get four or
five people want to be my business
network why I got no money I can't do
nothing you don't want to network know
what network what and talk about what my
people know how you doing professionally
I'm not doing that profession I'm
sitting here with a [ __ ] little Jew
from Boston who kicked the [ __ ] out of
me and jujitsu you know that's all I'm
[ __ ] doing what am i doing I'm not
doing nothing what am I gonna talk to
you about and I'm not problems [ __ ] you
didn't make it LinkedIn and count and
have it just be I'm not doing nothing
and then they leave you alone but here's
the thing
I never set one up you must have clicked
on it some at some point maybe people
just putting your name in
my people got a bargain I'm gonna buy I
don't want to [ __ ] I don't know
Instagram that means I got to take
pictures right I don't want to do that
easy
that's to sprint the [ __ ] Wi-Fi I
can't send pictures I can't send
pictures and nothing no more Jesus
Christ Joey 500 milligrams
what's another not really I don't really
have a choice what live there was a lot
of fun man
yeah you said thank you for spending
time with my dad by the way heat
applause yeah he's a good dude like I
said you're very fortunate to still have
them just sitting there with him just
brought back you know it just made me
realize how lucky you were like how
lucky a lot of people walk they had dads
around to see you there you know and
sometimes I'm like why doesn't Lee live
close to death you know why don't you
guys live together share an apartment
like Oscar and Felix and I understood
the other night yeah he's a great guy I
would have morale but I understand how
you want your space you know you want
your you don't want your dad to see you
dad to see you he would hear me having
sex with Paula right like a couple times
an apartment has popped up like in the
building of Paula's and I'll see a sound
I'll joke I didn't maybe what's moving
down there and I couldn't even imagine
like how would we ever be able to have
sex again if we live in the same
building as that's her mom so ya know I
love my dad but he he's happy down there
yeah he we wouldn't we wouldn't be all
up together I lit I love no no but I'm
not even talking about you I'm talking
about just sometimes I see some people
make a work though some people have like
Johnny Walker has a great relationship
with his parents and where they live I
don't know where they lived he lives
with them I don't know where they live
but some people make it work my parents
were alive and they have a house that
garage would be the [ __ ] million
dollar garage understand my still at 50
if you hadn't gotten married
nobody I see you [ __ ] moving
out creating debt you don't need you're
so [ __ ] stupid
you're so [ __ ] stupid it's crazy it's
well maybe it's because you have a
little ass yeah
I didn't have well nothing you didn't
have it and I wish I had it
I wish listen okay here it is plain and
[ __ ] simple okay this is what I wish
would have happened that had somewhere
to stay with no rent how was 2425 that's
what I wish to give me that little jump
start that little jump start really
given me enough for a car I could down
school I could've done a lot of things
and I had friends who stayed at home
longer but under the right circumstances
of your parents owned the home and your
parents are comfortable and they had a
couple bedrooms downstairs you know
there's some family is that it doesn't
know you know you take the garbage out
you mow the lawn ryan' shovel the snow
so what and then you say [ __ ] six
hundred a month seven hundred a month
all those years that your friends are
already getting that right out to
college I want you to hear me out hear
what I'm saying to you hear those two
years after college are [ __ ] crucial
a [ __ ] crucial it's okay you you got
a gig you got a gig making pizzas and
your valet park and the valet job pays
you 300 on Friday nights and Saturday
nights right so you basically got no
social right now you're interviewing to
get the job that you want to college for
but the whole time you're paying six
bills a month rent and you're paying
your student loans or whatever you could
defer for a year or whatever the [ __ ]
the deal you only get six months six
months or whatever so tell me I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking rate teen
you come out when you're 20 to 21 right
you need two years just two years in the
basement two years that you do your own
lines you give your mom a 50 you drive
your dad to a doctor you Mulder lon
ain't too badly well so what happens if
three months and you got a job are you
still staying
there because that's where I where I'm
like no I would stay there until I got a
little jump-start Li I would stay that
tongue out a little jump-start so I go
to college and I got a job making any
grantham I'm a [ __ ] year
let's pretend 48 5 I'm staying at my
mother's I'm staying on that [ __ ]
basement for another 2 years
so I get so they throw me out I don't
think it's good I think I see a lot of
people doing that now and like they
don't know how to deal with buying
furniture paint a stand I'm not talking
about mom I'm living downstairs and
you're doing everything I'm talking my
mom I'm taking over the downstairs I'm
gonna paint it I'm gonna put that [ __ ]
in storage I'm gonna put a little wall
over there I'm gonna put some rat traps
and some my strap downstairs ain't
cooking downstairs but I'm gonna put a
couch downstairs in a bed I've seen a
thousand my friends do it
thousand of my friends have converted
beautiful downstairs basements beautiful
you can't disrespect and you can't do
blow and bring [ __ ] over there like
it like that but you know what usually
you meet a girl and it all works out I
would I'm telling you a little cushion
always gonna help you out when I was 21
20 22 23
you have no idea that's all I was
praying for was a cushion and I had had
one with the Bendis and I blew it
I had one right when my mom died with
the Bendis I could have stayed that till
whatever but I blew it and then I found
another with the runnings it was like 40
hours a week was 200 a month that's not
bad
okay and you you follow me 200 a month
it's better than 800 a month especially
you could sneak upstairs and get a
meatball sandwich or get cereal milk
something to bail you out in the morning
when you're hungry yeah I don't know
maybe I'm just I mean I think I
definitely see I could see that you
wanted to fly the coop oh yeah listen I
flew the coop at [ __ ] 19 I flew the
coop two and I knew I was always gonna
fly the coop
I didn't know when but I always knew
like Texas people were talking about
in Houston and Colorado and California
but we're really surprised me by
Colorado was that every time I watch
something ABC especially as a child they
always said you know six o'clock Pacific
seven o'clock mountain so I had to get
an encyclopedia find out what - I was
out in town timezone was and I looked at
those states and I'm going my own way in
Colorado you know I think it's Utah I
forget which one up north more but I was
like this is this is amazing nobody
talks about these states nobody talks
about just in the same time zone seems
like a few it was oh it [ __ ] with me
it [ __ ] up me it [ __ ] up me
constantly like that's why I went to
Colorado that's one of the main reasons
are the mountains because if [ __ ] of
me how was Italy talked about it did you
like it yeah I sure I liked it I ended
up living there dying there you know
getting the boy yeah liked it but it was
all yeah I tell you where else as a
child intrigued the [ __ ] out of me
Seattle Washington why I don't know
because of the SuperSonics and the
seventies having a series I was one to
live in New York City
did you yeah in the summer by Seattle
just hearing about Seattle that
intrigued me
yeah and then maybe seven I watched the
Goodfellas and they talked about Seattle
that's where Henry Hill was I'm like I
can't believe all these crazy people is
Seattle then in 94
copain they're from Seattle I'm like
[ __ ] Seattle isn't the news again
and then at night I told you that I
would go home and the the commie
newspaper at the time right was
published out of San Francisco Just for
Laughs comedy newspaper was published
out of San Francisco but the guy booked
San Fran Reno and Seattle so in all the
issues
of that newspaper he always had the
logos for those clubs and I would always
look at the Seattle logo and go wow
someday if I ever get funny I'm gonna
play that [ __ ] Club I swear to God if
I have it get funny
I'm gonna play that [ __ ] Club I'm
gonna figure out how to play the
underground has a [ __ ] MC or a feature
did he play it listen dog and I [ __ ]
got into comedy and I was into it three
four years and I featured and
Minneapolis Minnesota and Michigan I'm
sorry and I met this girl and I go what
are you doing she goes I'm moving to see
how in a week and I know why I go up
there and see on the way to cholera I'm
the way to Seattle stop in Colorado and
see me and that's crazy cow and I ended
up in Seattle Jesus and then but did you
play that club down the ground yeah
first club I ever did a feature spot at
in my life I opened up for glory kid
Martin
I had them sieved before Adam seen at
the club in Baltimore I had them seen at
one of the clubs in Denver I had em seen
and uh so you traveled as an emcee yeah
300 a week for like [ __ ] 19 show
Jesus Christ I didn't know that Michigan
hired me
Baltimore hind me one of the club's and
then behind me
you
before never mind the [ __ ] comedy
underground
and I was gonna move back to Boulder to
do the sports betting service I moved to
Seattle in June okay
and football starts in August by the end
of August he came to me he could by
middle of August they called me and said
you want to feature we'll give you a
featured spot the first week of
September I was like [ __ ] football
I'm staying here on feature and I
featured and that's a feature in there
I got a bunch of little jobs and I said
listen I want to be back for October so
I started my own sports betting service
and I got another call and they're like
listen we want you to [ __ ] it we want
see that we want you to do the Seattle
Comedy competition starts in November so
I said well I mean I do I'm gonna call
this guy [ __ ] I just stopped my own
sports betting service I was gonna say
you like made a choice I like comedy
like that's pretty close but then how do
you start your own betting service you
just taking bets are you know because
the sports betting services basically
when you sell somebody information which
is when a person knows people who knows
people who give you the scores and know
referees the game into were your
references at this point I know a couple
visits and new people I know a guy who
play hockey like that not I just listen
you just have a hunch I listen when I
when I work for the sports betting
service that I work for it was basically
three or four guys that made a decision
that had been involved in it for a long
time and really knew the game that made
a decision but one of the things he told
me once that really stuck out my mind
guys won't I want you to know something
Petros was betting on baseball and he
was losing arch Switzer was betting on
football and he was losing and there's a
bunch of other names that he dropped and
they were losing they actually played
the game what makes you think we could
be accurate well I don't understand what
he meant by that these guys were playing
the [ __ ] game oh and they were bad
regard damn day and they were losing
okay you know I'm saying they were in
volatile with the quarterback with the
Indianapolis cult way before you even
thought about [ __ ] football you were
still sucking your mom's teddy and when
he was throwing touchdowns he was
betting on football he was the first guy
to get banned if you want to
double-check the NFL all right sweet sir
was the first boy I think he was on
Indianapolis when they were something
else before they were the coach they
were the Indianapolis sometimes well the
Baltimore Colts well this is when they
were Indianapolis before all that [ __ ]
went down and I felt alright sweet sir
SCH L itz NFL quarterback he's the first
guy to get [ __ ] fans I think Lee I
look I'll keep looking for it that's not
exposing so he once said he goes if all
these guys were playing the game and
losing what makes you think we could bet
this [ __ ] that's crazy and but did he
were they involved with those like what
the throw in the game so they later
doesn't know all they did was make a
prediction they're like us how can they
make a prediction when people are
cheating that's what they're saying no
no nobody's saying about not about
cheating well isn't on James you know
they were throwing games a sports
betting service isn't throwing game no
I'm saying the players no no our cholito
is betting on himself whatever I don't
know what the [ __ ] he was doing okay I
don't know if he was throwing games or
just betting other football games
sometimes they just bet other games so
they don't [ __ ] know do you find them
saying to you alright so if I'm a
quarterback for the Jets
and I'm betting the [ __ ] Buffalo
Miami game okay yeah I'm saying I played
against both those [ __ ] right I
know I know both their defenses I know
what both those quarterbacks could do
I've been playing football since I'm
[ __ ] seven right to be an NFL
quarterback
you just don't decide to be a
quarterback when you're in college and
start throwing [ __ ] darts you've been
throwing darts is [ __ ] peewee
football right now so you know this game
then all sudden here you are and you're
a [ __ ] junkie you're a betting fiend
and you're gambling and you can't
[ __ ] pick a win it do you farm saying
to yourself you're gonna felt playing
you can't pick a winner what does that
tell you that you kidding nobody can
nobody can so right nobody could be as
accurate as say they can so here I am
living in [ __ ] Seattle right I'm
hustling I'm doing little [ __ ] videos
for industrials for AT&T and companies
like that that mailing me checks I'm
getting $50 the show here I'm living
with this broad you know she spends with
three and she's a [ __ ] stripper I got
no way to make a living and go [ __ ] it
I'm just gonna do the sports but
anything on my own and how do you
advertise that okay nice and easy
I bump into the zoo is where knows a
dude who works for a [ __ ] phone
company oh yeah this is the craziest
thing ever
I'm thinking about it for like two weeks
cuz now I gotta stay there and I'm a
Josh wolf place or maybe I'm at the
underground see the comedy underground
upstairs have a sports bar and that's
what all those sports people are not
demand this I'm not there and the
football player sent out that see hug
the Seahawks not the basketball team
they were black down outs on the other
side of town different they hung out on
a jazz club no I'm not trying to be cute
I'm telling you the truth okay but my
comedian friend
they hang out of a different atmosphere
that I would a place where people drank
wine or if it was beautiful I went a
couple times of Ronghua he took me a
couple times but the other place was
like Ronny McDowell we used to hang out
with Pearl Jam and foul
you know I don't even remember the
football players from Seattle that I'm
out there but they were like bar guys
you know right the offensive line okay
so I bump into this [ __ ] dude we're
just talking one day and he's telling me
that he's working for some phone company
and they give you an 800 number for free
if you subscribe to the service it's
eight cents a minute I don't [ __ ]
know you know me I'm sniffing the
company anyway doesn't matter what rate
they give me as long as we could do
paperwork and there's no down payment
let's do it so I start talking like I
take his car just God goes take his car
I take this card one day I'm gonna
[ __ ] newsstand by the newspaper and I
look down and I see the best hundred
sports betting services in the country I
pick it up I know it's [ __ ] right
off the bat this is all one company who
advertises and they put down everybody
else and they put them the top three
companies in the top five okay because
you just don't know them once betting
company you own three of them so I would
be Joey Diaz international sports right
you would be Lisa at the king of Israel
and then we have Sports mania offensive
money men from [ __ ] Syria and just
get all the business and then I am an
Arab guy to answer the phone and say
that there what's that what what's all
the way what's with the oil what's the
fake [ __ ] Island Oh Dubai Dubai say
that they're from Dubai sports guys in
Dubai get some [ __ ] Arabs answer
phone hello what's going on listen over
here we bet for thousands of dollars
that's all they want that's all the
sports betting services so I could
listen to what I [ __ ] do I read the
magazine I look at the guys to call and
I look where the magazine is printed who
puts it out and I get the information I
call this [ __ ] at the Rec and I
go listen dunk I know you're looking
over at this point
this is because I'm a savage right I
call this [ __ ] [ __ ] in San Diego I
live in Seattle and I go listen I just
picked up your magazine I worked through
a bah-bah-bah and I know what the [ __ ]
you're doing I go can you help me out I
think goes what are you talking about I
did a survey you did no [ __ ] survey
right here this is your address this is
your mailing this is where your money
look it's you can't be that [ __ ]
stupid I don't even have a [ __ ]
computer life is like a beautiful mind
of criminal like right you know what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you you as well
nah my partner he's the sports guy
I put the magazine out yeah okay okay
listen you're telling uncle Joey how do
you do your angle he goes well people
call me and I sign him up for the season
right there and who's why the guy was
[ __ ] right there why you don't want
to sign nobody wants to sign up for the
season they don't try you first they
want you to give him a free pic before
you give them the season two three picks
in the weekend for free you ain't got
that type of time you're gonna foil
before the season is over nobody says
stick around for a season people that
are new don't know this young gamblers
that lose a season then they don't know
this and what do you do you please
donate for the season yeah these morons
koala and they'll pay $9.99 for the
[ __ ] season and you get all the picks
every weekend you get picks well it
seems like a good deal to me now I'm
like right but that that means you're
with them what if they start losing that
the week four and they take you down at
the mochi let's [ __ ] roll of debt by
the time a week time you're gonna keep
calling these [ __ ] morons
how much is like a pig week by week
costs so now they would call and they
would go listen the package costs $15.99
I'm gonna do this
send me $9.99 today cuz I get you
started and after a couple weeks you
sent me to bounce I don't give a [ __ ]
about the bounce like I got you $9.99
already right all right so I go do me a
favor when people call you
[ __ ] names of the people who don't
sign up with you you would say that yeah
and he goes okay what a why can't I go
outside give you I don't know what deal
I caught with him I cut some funky deal
with him but I had to do with me not
spilling the beans on his [ __ ]
magazine I know that okay I know he did
something we did we work something out
he would not email me we do what he
faxed me the names yes he was faxed me
the names the people who called him but
didn't pay that's a [ __ ] up way to
start a business
listen to me so I would get those leads
from him do not leave those elites those
will leave but they didn't want fine so
what they didn't want to buy from him
they didn't hear on for Joey's [ __ ] oh
okay so boom I call you up with the same
piece of paper he's got see he wanted to
sign them off for this season right okay
999 I come and I go listen Lisa at whose
dish this is Joe Paterno's [ __ ]
nephew alright here's what would I'm
sorry I just said I don't know why I
said that
whose joy bananas who enjoyed bananas I
work for [ __ ] all-star sports
you called us a month ago looking for
the season yeah man interesting hold on
hold on let me talk to you about
something man
hold on you spoke to my partner Mike
right yeah but he wanted $9.99 for the
[ __ ] seat that's why I'm calling you
listen to me my name is Joe bananas I've
been around the [ __ ] block alright
I've been running with the big boys for
18 [ __ ] years I make my living off
this [ __ ] when you were [ __ ] you know
jerking off with your friends I was
hanging out with Joe Namath's Martin
[ __ ] coke off chicks titties finger
banging [ __ ] mr. Dyk and people go
who's this was this who gave me my
number who and I just blow him away and
I go listen I don't want to work with
you for a season I don't want to work
with nobody first season I'm gonna do
this
send me 200 to get started for $2,000
after I make you 2,000 miles you don't
wanna work with me no more you go your
way and I go my way how would you know
that they won mm they were just tell you
yeah they tell me what they're gonna bet
so then finally off the bat they're
telling me they've bet $50 a game that
means they've been 5 on our game oh it's
under I've working to be over there
always lying
I always whine they're always lying to
you so I would call these guys up let's
say my name is whatever I'm not gonna
lie to you I give you two picks a week
you bet him for 15 that's $3,000 at the
end of the month here up 12 [ __ ]
thousand how much you're gonna like me
then but I'll tell you what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna give you 200 for 2010 points
and people were [ __ ] sign up I had
like 20 25 people one time but that
means every Saturday if I was on the
road in those days which I was they had
to get up a little pay phone and get a
quality card and call every [ __ ]
client with a game oh okay an operation
and then after you made them mm well
they re up for another 200 or do your
other do you know the 200 wouldn't
didn't do 2,000 will never come no I'm
I'd go into them the next day if they
want better tactics I learned when I
worked for the company and they'd have
to pay for the new one again
[ __ ] yeah that's why I made my money so
if I called you up right and you said to
me well I'm broke I already lost the
[ __ ] weekend but I have a Baba I go
right 300 and 300 and 300 but three on
the grain three on the total and 300
parlay that's [ __ ] you know that's
that's a thousand fifty all right so
you're halfway there guess where you
call the first thing tomorrow morning
guess what the first core you gonna make
after you will a thousand dollars
gu10 me joy bananas all [ __ ] great night
last night what do you got for me today
listen this is where it gets bad what
are you talking about the information I
got from the [ __ ] Juke fell through
what do you mean it fell to earth fell
through I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened so what that mean yes that
means we gotta go to an outside source
what's that mean it means that it's
gonna cost us more [ __ ] money around
and I'm not [ __ ] happy I was supposed
to go on a [ __ ] cruise to see
Jerusalem him and he [ __ ] Jesus
it murdered him and [ __ ] I think I feel
I got the grandmother the mother-in-law
and they go what are you talking about
yeah it's gonna cost me in $1,000 so
this is why I need for you to do okay I
just broke it up amongst my partners do
me a [ __ ] favor go to Western you
leave what are you talking about go to
Western you go down the Western Union
send me 1500 [ __ ] dollars Joe what
are you talking about I need 15 I'll
listen listen to me you won't how much
last night a thousand but that's not why
I agreement listen I know you want a
thousand dollars you want a thousand
dollars with four-star information I'm
gonna call this guy right now this guy
that walks around with a suitcase with a
handcuff on it man
okay I need [ __ ] 1250 I thought you
said 50 listen I'm gonna cut you a deal
I need 1750 send me 1250 right [ __ ]
now and we're gonna get the game in a
[ __ ] year you got can you better stop
hundred thousand tonight Joe what are
you talking about I only bet 500 listen
are you [ __ ] listening to me you did
that were charged you [ __ ] 1250 if
I'm not gonna make you $100,000 tonight
I want you to start I want you to go to
Western Union sent me to 1250 call me
back with a 10-digit confirmation then
call me back I want you to tell me how
many bookies you could put $10,000 and
buy click and then what do you say when
your team loses do you think I'm [ __ ]
happy the [ __ ] information fell you
would you lose I lost 150 thousand if
you lost hundred fifty thousand you know
what I lost you miserable [ __ ] I
lost three hundred thousand-plus I'm not
going to Europe plus my wife left me for
the [ __ ] [ __ ] down the corner cuz
it's got a bigger dick on me with so you
ain't got nothing your [ __ ] call me back
later I'll give you the game with a
weekend I just hang upon and they call
you back and give me more waiting like
nothing they wouldn't give me more money
than I gotta win him an envelope but I
know people who used to going right
there for him again down under 50 grand
now what are you gonna do now we gotta
go to the big leagues I thought that was
the bigger that that was nothing this is
a rat for the NFL so how often were you
going to Western Union do you know just
even like an account there oh [ __ ] yeah
you have somebody who just picks up cash
from Western you know all day long I
can't believe you weren't like that's
what I did a funny bone in head we're
sitting at a payphone with the picks of
the week
what if I'm in Oregon one time in the
other the other side of Washington
Basco or something like that it's this a
disco inferno and they're not the comedy
room did we 10% off a breakfast lunch
and dinner Jesus Christ the food was bad
what are you gonna do that's how you
start a homily man at least you got 10%
on your play some music and I'll [ __ ]
sit there like a putz
I am one step ahead e well you know you
like that's like
what's up though
stooge it was fun today well be less
don't come crying everybody's you soon
I'm not crying I want to go I look at
your [ __ ] Savage I like it in the
smaller classes Hassan killed me on
Thursday we were doing the anaconda one
the opposite of the DARS and [ __ ]
killed me but it's a boys can better
look at you shrinking you get more
muscular based on the other [ __ ] be
able to join the mr. Olympia contest in
shape war without a strip my plate the
people oh if I ever get a six-pack I'm
never wearing a shirt that's gonna be
great not even a six-pack just flat I
love a man with goals you got goals look
he's got about six packs and [ __ ]
twelve but not even packs just your
[ __ ] on him I used to go to 24 Hour
Fitness he told the second dick it's
over you agency I don't know what to do
now cuz like I put a year and do it to
like my rates lower now and probably I'd
be someone on the weekends
you won't people let me not work out for
three days but now it's like Teddy but
come on you still you still that [ __ ]
stupid Stairmaster without the hands
yeah no no let's do bothered about games
there's break the record to them what
the [ __ ] you only live once I might do
it yeah there's a full moon tonight you
got a chicken cordon bleu laugh at that
I got a box left yeah I'll eat pieces of
the Bucks I get the big bucks business
safe 6:01 over there ladies some chicken
cordon bleu
okay watch some late-night television
wait think we're gonna let eat another
star definitely might as well at this
point
everyone emails me like Oh first of all
there's always a reason there should be
a little [ __ ] black kids will be both
hoping they have a star of death
somewhere right now in [ __ ] Africa
somewhere there's somewhere in Iowa same
I wish you had to start dead let's do it
for a bulletin and you're [ __ ]
sitting there going I mean six [ __ ]
stir who gives a [ __ ] you can't walk on
one leg please remember I won't be
walking you're as tough as nails you got
open anyone a speed dial don't you
I might have to tonight yeah [ __ ]
five well you look you sash
no where's that piece ass yeah we've got
alone it's there for mending I can have
10 da just coming here right now they
couldn't find that [ __ ] I'm gonna
talk no breaks no it was really nice I
saw earlier Oh sign saying you've dead
Vicky cyan he had a good time
[ __ ] plates that good Chinese food
you're saying the hell told me every
nail like the fried rice and dumplings
the house fried rice is very nice I
don't know what that guys I'm not a
[ __ ] casino guy I have an abacus you
know guy [ __ ] no I don't like no place
don't when I walk in there that Parag
Alyssa take my [ __ ] money
what's up what are you looking up at the
[ __ ] ceiling full your eyes are all
right will or anything when you walk
into a civilian here's for when you walk
into a casino their prerogatives just
take your [ __ ] Jesus right but you
don't feel like that no yes it does it
does I think they think you know when
you see a slot machine you won't
down that alleyway it's like going down
an alleyway and seeing a hooker
yeah the slot machines I don't really
get talking there's good at him but
that's not how I feel that's I like I
love gamblin everybody brought some
props to do talking layer called the San
Diego ready to the game yesterday he
called the Raiders I did he really
okay you win your money last time
don't [ __ ] we're talking let talking
their lives in it we want to be slain
that's right some people have a hard
time winning one [ __ ] game you blast
them with two [ __ ]
but uh I whenever I go no casino I don't
feel like I'm gonna lose everyone says
that but at my head I'm gonna like you
didn't say I didn't say that in my mind
I think I'm gonna go in there with
that's how you mind [ __ ] with you right
yeah but you also know that their
prerogative is to take your money
nothing else from the minute you walk in
and you going up to that [ __ ] table
and you beautiful girl comes up to me
and says what are we drinking tonight
and you're like oh [ __ ] and it's a whole
illusion how they really really get you
and don't get me wrong it's fun i sat
there i people watch i think people
watch when you're [ __ ] high is
brilliant it's pretty great you know
they had a great food court and they had
pizza there so every night for the show
I want another slice of pizza and i sat
there one night with deke and i sat
there yeah that one my friends which I
hung out with Lisa at since the sixth
grade in North Bergen
Carlos Perez Cathy Cal toes my Quinet I
mean I'm sitting there but not how lucky
it sometimes you hang out with four
people that are from Mia high school no
no no no no no no no these were three
people that were from my neighborhood
giving that terrorist Charles Court 38th
Street Park or and it was just the
conversations we had were [ __ ]
amazing but the one thing that I I
realized while they were there is I'm on
stage talking about sensitivity and all
this [ __ ] how Martina and muddy called
his brother Martin the [ __ ] brother had
a store on 40 41st Street and it was
called herb I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was called his name was Herman and
the wife made Cuban steak sandwiches in
the back like three bucks and we play a
couple games of basketball we got hungry
walk over there I don't know name of the
store was because they just called it
the [ __ ] door that's it that's what
they call that that's what it was that's
what it was but guess what the other
store wasn't our neighborhood what store
the [ __ ] store oh yeah we know we went
in there oh yeah used to be called
dragon grocery worth growing up was a
Cuban Chinese guy who had a beautiful
Chinese daughter and a beautiful little
boy if I'm 50 they the girl's got to be
48 47 you know the daughter Wow it's
only a few years old on Sundays they
would make the best pork fried rice and
the best broke just roast pork
Jakub a slice then with the [ __ ]
seeds forget about it you'd sit there
like [ __ ] what that I do deserve this
[ __ ] greatness in the [ __ ] store now
maybe the Chino store the [ __ ] store
and the [ __ ] boy that's the sensitivity
in our [ __ ] neighborhood and what do
you say - listen alone er no they knew
it they had heard the rumor you know
eventually you heard the [ __ ] room oh
Jesus Christ
how [ __ ] crazy and I said it on stage
and my Quinet and Pablo's afterwards we
were laughing on out there like how
crazy is that
that was it the chinks door what are you
going through the chinks door do you
want anything you walk on that [ __ ]
hell it's 90 degrees [ __ ] let's give
it a shot
but how lucky was I that the Cathy cows
and
tell them I'm playing basketball on that
basketball court what's the matter what
you see you seen things good for you
no okay Jesus Christ yeah that's right
it's a full moon
oh we think so we spell hit Assam now
just a little one
there's no such thing of the little big
ones up damage oh no I think I think 625
is good no the kettle bell class
tomorrow I could punch in the moon which
would be good cause she'll stick a
needle in me to decipher Nate the acid
into all the parts of my body no I just
made up a [ __ ] I love it I got it
tomorrow's the first time in acupuncture
in like four weeks you excited
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you been down in Marina
del Rey ah but now she's got all her
clients back see the summer ended it's
none of the clients are back everybody's
ready to get acupuncture for the winter
so she told me she's back here for the
next four Tuesdays so by next week I'll
be hung keep doing the same hunk hit a
Dewey I don't even know what that
[ __ ] word means I'm just dropping it
on Lisa at with 625 milligrams of THC
edible debt that's it now are we gonna
go to the hospital to give you the rest
of this bat bag because I gonna do get
high with Paul in them yeah you guys go
you five just to open up the game no you
don't yes you do three is good maybe
three and 100 are they selling the green
ones yet I'm not sure okay well no I can
we talk about it I'm not sure okay yeah
we're not the green ones the 15
milligrams and then I'm gonna release
these purple ones
the two large employer they the common
job the green ones tasted great their
lemon-lime yeah they were delicious
delicious and these red ones don't taste
bad
no no bad what's the purple ones taste
like to you not bad you said family
tastes much into the time delay yeah
they work another 200 because I spoke to
you and you hi yeah and I was pretty
high and I passed the [ __ ] out I woke up
thirsty as a [ __ ] like at 3 in
the morning but he'll sleep apnea
massive falling off the whole [ __ ]
deal that's you know it's uh I'm really
lucky even when I said like the ladies
and gentlemen there's four people in the
audience that I grew up with no don't
listen to these stories they're [ __ ]
back there laughing you know and he died
when I talked about marathon woman he
[ __ ] died well he came out marathon
woman was a girl who sucks sixteen dicks
when we were in high school I was not
there I heard the story she did
you
who is pimple around well it's pink that
was making us soaked like Jimmy then he
would walk up to you they actually give
me a hug and go Coco how you doing this
is what I've got named after 10 minutes
he look Easley well you dick sucking you
know what he thought I don't know just
tell me a [ __ ] company what a blow
job yet
and he look at this girl go suck that
dick and she'd given the person he'd
suck she'd suck it Dickinson suck my
dick and then she'd go back to him and
they'd walk away it was crazy you have
good friends but he never did you know
Jimmy done he never oh you never had no
no no no I was not one of the lucky guys
I always missed it by 20 minutes I was
always one of ourselves and then he was
telling the story that he was there the
one night when she blew a 19 guys and
there was still like four guys in the
room and she came out and she said
that's it like this girl was a nut this
girl was a [ __ ] nuts on ISIL and
[ __ ] high school
so he just had heard the story to know
he was there I mean those guys you know
that been put this can Carlos Perez de
came to the [ __ ] show him and I used
to do THC crystal when we were 14
on Sundays for about three or four
months me and the skinny Cuban kid would
get high and then here we go his way and
I would go my way and he would we
weren't allowed to tell nobody that we
had gotten high together we didn't want
anybody know we were doing THC crystal
so we would do it and then go on our own
ways sometimes we'd hang for like an
hour and then he'd go meet a girl and
then go meet some guys and play
basketball or some [ __ ] that's how long
I know cause that's causing me go back
all the way to give it that terrorist
how do you keep me technically feel I
didn't talk to Carlos for a long time I
always because I lost contact with
Carlos probably at 18 and between you
and I always loved Carlos Carlos was one
of those kids early on that just he was
just my friend I just know he was one of
my friends when our bond was that we
were the only Spanish kids in the
neighborhood you know when you're the
only two Spanish kids they get accepted
like that you have a certain boss and he
was about Shanno kid also you know he
was tight with Jimmy and I was tight
with Anthony we were all tight so you
were tight with the bowels and he would
tie it with everybody so this made us
really tight him and I and after Anthony
died we became even tighter and
he hung around with my friend Dominic
that drowned Wow when there was some way
when we were juniors but the the story
is a week and I wasn't hassle about this
because I've heard it a thousand times
and I know it's true the story is that
one night Carlos and Dominic busted into
a Chevy store in West Bergen
we lived I'd have to call it a mile from
where we lived we grew up and took the
Corvette and throw out the front front
window and Bobby Benton when I went home
this last time we were eating lunch and
it goes if I ever tell you that I shot a
gun at those guys the night they stole
the vet and a couple days later he goes
I never got the seed Dominic a guy knew
was him you know say was I was on duty
and I recognized them running they left
the car started running because they
reported a suspicious car that when I've
been taken out of the showroom at
McGuire Chevrolet whatever the [ __ ] it
was it was the one closer to a house it
wasn't my wife Shepherd is it a mile
from where you guys live yeah I'm Kelly
Boulevard which is like a Main Street
but still we were like you know down the
[ __ ] block a mile that's what we grew
up they weren't that great of thieves
no they were crazy they were crazy kids
I tell you know I tell you these [ __ ]
stories we think that we grew up [ __ ]
trading baseball cards and and going to
baseball games of the glove and waiting
for the ball to land no I'm telling you
that I'm when I was nine we walked to a
[ __ ] movie theater I'm telling you
that no these kids weren't [ __ ] you
ordinary kids but they're still around
and Kathy couch knows the girl that came
yeah we all went to the same grammar
school the only outsider in that circle
was Carlos his wife but of the four
people five people at the table four of
us had gone through the same grammar
school at the same time me Mike when
that Carlos and this Kathy help those
not only that I was tight with Kathy
councils two brothers I was real tight
with Pauly when I play basketball Paul
he would put Led Zepplin live in the
window of his house and I can hear it I
would shoot baskets to listen to [ __ ]
let them live yeah that's how in fact I
go with them that's how back I go with
the calvo's so she you know here's a
girl that was a but when I first knew
Kathy she was very quiet and shy like
Rocky's wife like not [ __ ] but she
was really like you know quiet Mike and
she got married and I guess the [ __ ]
she didn't have a wife for twenty years
and then she went to a wake and she met
a guy awake and she divorced her husband
and married this guy the wake and after
two years of that guy she realized she
just didn't want to be married so she
divorced him she got a makeover and
she's a completely different woman man
and I was looking like this girl just
laughing the whole night because I know
what she was and I know what she became
even if she became that later on in life
she still got it one day she goes it
didn't take me beats about forty to
realize I had raised a child I didn't
want to be married no more and I didn't
want to [ __ ] be him I didn't want to
be told what to do because I live by
myself I have my own condo now I come
and go as I please and she was a family
great time she doesn't leave here I
might have a boutique or I might be able
to just to go home a little better I'm a
mom I mind but that's what I always
wanted to do and she goes for 20 [ __ ]
he is I gave my life to
married and cooking and you know she
goes now for what my kids they live in
Nebraska they go to college they call me
once a week you know she goes and this
is what I just wanted to [ __ ] get my
life together and be who I wanted to be
it was really weird because I never
heard somebody like she said that's it I
stopped everything and took care of me
for once and it's really weird when
people realize that everybody at one
point in their life realize that when
they like why the [ __ ] am I getting up
and gonna do this [ __ ] today I'm taking
care of [ __ ] me and once you get that
attitude your life [ __ ] change this
mess that's a hard because they you
always hear like you have to know it
like you always say don't stop working
like you don't need days off all that
stuff no but she meant it in a way that
she was trapped like she was married and
she was trying for her it's cool and I
just always had a good job she works you
know she's something for like a ship
line like those ships that people were
those people that go on those things and
they go from city to city in Mexico
you know cruise lines so she goes on a
lot of cruise lines because she works
for them oh cause like some bigshot she
makes a great salary she works in sales
well she's a big shot oh no I think
that's pretty like that's great
especially if she wasn't like if the
kids are out of the house well her point
was that she was married you know for
all that time she had children and then
she thought that it was that she didn't
want to be with that guy so she married
a different guy well I know the second
guy she married really well I know it
was a joke on him I know him really well
growing up him and his brother and I
knew his dad was a cop I know I all of
him we always giggles together and she
said that she still talks to him
but after a year being married to him
she realized she just didn't want to be
married that she went from a marriage
where she raised a child and had a
husband and she cooked and you know she
this was a college sweetheart and that
whole [ __ ] thing to being a mom above
all all since she got out of that so
please another [ __ ] husband once you
get married again you gotta start from
scratch with another guy you got a
family what he likes
you don't like meatloaf with onions you
know he likes his pants [ __ ] dried
and hung in the Sun with lemon detergent
and one day she goes you know Joey I
just woke up and said that's it I'm not
doing this no more she goes I